son salon est aménagé en salle de
méditation Roberts pratique l'art du zen
dans la pièce surplombant le parc Dahan
grand parc de Taipei défendre Taïwan
selon lui et son devoir de bouddhiste
celui de prévenir un désastre pointe à
l'horizon
inspiré par la résilience ukrainienne le
milliardaire taïwanais promet de donner
100 millions de dollars américains pour
former les civils au combat 3 millions
de personnes en trois ans dont 300000
tireurs d'élite
il souhaite développer à Taïwan la
détermination et une plus grande volonté
de défendre l'île c'est d'autant plus
important selon lui que le président
chinois si j'ai une vient d'obtenir un
troisième mandat
le milliardaires de l'électronique a
déjà contourné les lois pour brasser des
affaires en Chine il avait renoncé à sa
citoyenneté tawanaise jusqu'à récemment
mais Roberts est maintenant en croisade
contre les communistes chinois qu'il
qualifie deux zombies
et contre le président chinois Silling
responsable selon lui du démantèlement
de Hong Kong et de possibles crimes
contre l'humanité dans le signe John
Taïwan joue un rôle crucial dans la
production des micro-processeurs ce qui
inciterait les États-Unis et le Japon a
supporté à sa défense selon plusieurs
analystes mais attention à cette notion
de bouclier de silicium averti Roberts
la Chine pourrait tout aussi prendre en
otage TSMC le plus gros joueur mondial
des semi-conducteurs afin d'obtenir le
contrôle de Taïwan en échange
des propos qui tranchent à Taïwan la
majorité des résidents affirment qu'ils
sont habitués aux menaces chinoises et
qu'ils ne sont pas inquiets
un faux sentiment de sécurité selon lui
la preuve que les mentalités doivent
changer
de pratiquer le zen et le bouddhisme
c'est vivre dans le moment présent et la
menace contre Taïwan est immédiate selon
Roberts il suffit Leblanc Radio-Canada